when the most powerful moments in the
movie The Dark Knight is the opening
sequence this scene we find the Joker
orchestrating a clockwork precision bank
heist as the robbery plays out though we
discovered there's something else
altogether going on and this bank heist
also becomes a statement of what the
Joker stands for for chaos or rather
more specifically an upside down clown
hierarchy for the rest of the guys this
scene is one of the most succinctly Oz
ever made of a revolution it can help us
understand contemporary phenomena like
canceled culture and other upside-down
structures which like the serpent of
chaos always end up devouring themselves
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
the scene follows a group of robbers and
clown masks the spoils are supposed to
be separated equitably to the group but
each of the participants think that
they're in on a little secret when the
first robber finishes his job with the
alarm the one responsible for opening
the vault kills him shot in the back and
as the vault guy is doing what he's
there for he tells the next robber whose
job it is to fill up the money bags that
boss told me when the guy was done I
should take him out one less share of
course the money bag guy has been told a
similar story so when the vault is open
he takes out his collaborator as well at
this point the money bag guy thinks he's
figured it out so in order to stop the
dominoes from falling decides to take
things into his own hands I'm betting
the Joker told you to kill me as soon as
we loaded the cash but of course once
the gears of revolution have started
turning it is difficult to stop them
the bus driver runs him over and to
finish everything off the Joker who had
been hiding behind a mask this whole
time kills the bus driver and remains
alone on the Pyramid of bodies the
purpose of the whole process is not so
that the Joker can keep all the money to
himself the Joker doesn't care about
that he tells us why he did it when the
bank manager asks him what do you
believe in I believe whatever doesn't
kill you simply makes
it's time to turn it is to crystallize
his position as the king of the
margarine the emperor of what is strange
we've just witnessed an upside-down
hierarchy
playing itself out in a normal hierarchy
there's an exchange between the top and
the bottom the higher aspects of
hierarchies give organization identity
sense of unity and cohesion to what is
below to provide a plan the lower rungs
of a hierarchy provide potential a body
to the identity specificity two general
rules that make it possible for a plan
to be executed each level of a hierarchy
both received unity and what is above in
exchange of body and multiplicity but it
also provides unity for what is below
this is of course true of human systems
like governments so a nation provides
unity to provinces and states states
provide unity to two cities cities
provide unity to neighborhoods down to
streets to houses to rooms and we could
continue down all the way to the quantum
level all of these levels provide
potential to embody their identity from
below a country or any other level of
the hierarchy cannot exist in a world
with without all the lower levels of
reality constituting them this is the
fractal structure of reality The Joker
scene we're seeing how chaos appears as
an upside down hierarchy it's not normal
business transaction we're purposeful
objects and services are exchanged for
the potential that is money rather this
is a robbery where all the souls for
rules of exchange break down to
emphasize the chaos as a turning wheel
it is important that all of this is
happening through a bunch of clowns the
pattern of the clown is in full force
because the entire robbery is set up as
a deadly practical joke as one clown
finishes playing a trick on the other he
quickly realizes that the joke is on him
and as the wheel turns and turns only
the king of the upside down is left
standing
made more powerful for having
orchestrated this gauntlet the phrase
like Saturn the revolution eats itself
was coined by a French Royalists named
Jacques Malaga during the French
Revolution and it's remained that key
phrase in
understanding the side-effects of
revolutionary action as the pattern goes
Saturn had castrated his father hora
knows which is heaven itself was the
first act of revolution and was done to
free himself and his siblings from the
tyrannical order of the Father in doing
this Saturn acquired power to himself
but because the legitimacy of his own
power you know was in his heavenly
lineage by castrating heaven he also
destroyed his own legitimacy and opened
himself up to being questioned by his
own progeny and the only way to stop it
from perpetuating itself was to make a
purge he had to stop his own lineage
from existence in the Joker's story we
see how the first clown takes out the
one that preceded him and is then taken
out by the next by the third step the
clown with the moneybags understand that
the only way to stop this cascade of
destruction is to turn around and take
out the next in line before it happens
to him he doesn't succeed but if he has
succeeded of course we understand that
he would have had to take out the bus
driver there was no other solution once
the revolutionary wheel starts turning
there are many examples of this in
history which is why revolutions always
end up with purges the first to be
purged are of course the top elite
classes so as the noble used the
bourgeoisie to take up the king the
bourgeoisie then used the workers to
take out the nobles and so forth and so
forth until the system is burned to the
ground
the person who's able to stop it is the
one who's capable of both destroying
those from whom he takes power and then
also he's able to stop those next in
line so Stalin destroyed all his
contenders while also crushing those
beneath him once he had gained power the
most recent example of this shows itself
in the canceled culture of social
justice and intersectionality those who
want to destroy the patriarchy are
immediately suspect of being tools of
the patriarchy who must in their turn be
destroyed in order to prevent that there
has to be a purge of others one way or
another or else one risks being next in
the so in the line of the social
guillotine and so we see two strategies
being laid out the two strategies that
we
in the Joker scene one strategy is to
continue the revolution itself and so
more and more marginal or strange
identities must compete to emancipate
themselves Western feminists will accuse
Western men minority feminists will
accuse Western feminists LGBT activists
will accuse feminists trans activists
will accuse others in the LGBT coalition
minority trans activists well you know
you see the picture so the other
solution is the one taken by the money
bag clown in the movie trying to stop
the bleeding by purging the other way
and so then you'll find feminists
calling out trans activists for
destroying everything that they've built
and then you'll see some trans activists
resisting other nameless strange
marginal identities of course just like
the Joker the entire process is related
to a belief in how reality works a
competition to win the marginal kingship
to live out reality of the revolutionary
cycle which is that whatever doesn't
kill you makes you stronger
if you enjoyed this content and our
exploration of symbolism get involved I
love to read your insights and questions
in the comment section you can also
share this video on social media to your
friends as you can please consider
supporting us financially through
patreon or PayPal you'll find those
links in the description below
[Music]